well joining us now is dr michael greg
citis a consultant pediatric intensive
care doctor in southampton who was part
of the team that helped bring the
children over hello to you doctor thank
you for joining us um these little ones
have cancer but they are now uh here
safe in the uk tell us about their
journey
yeah thank you i would like to start off
by saying that actually
this was an incredible collaboration
across all parts of the nhs the
department of health and primarily
frontline children's hospitals that were
able to put together
um
critical care transport teams supported
by oncology colleagues
made up from university hospital of
southampton and birmingham children's
hospital and so we flew out to retrieve
21 children
receiving cancer therapies and with
actually very little information and
arrived to find
a situation that we were
you know we had no expectations of and
flew them back yesterday back to the uk
um successfully and this all happened
quite quickly quite efficiently and was
quite an emotional experience actually
obviously we want to not probe too
deeply into these um youngsters
conditions but i wondered if you could
give us an idea of their ages and and
what sort of conditions we're talking
about
yes actually i obviously can't go into
individual cases but i can tell you that
uh generically the age range was was
vast going from uh babies through to
teenagers um and
there was all different kinds of cancers
on the flight and it wasn't just one
type there was many many types of
different cancers
and
these children were all
of
varying degrees of illness some
critically ill and and
we were
just privileged and honored to be able
to help uh get them out of the country
and and get them to
england and the uk where we could
provide
support for them because without this
ongoing care they would die
how
did you choose which children needed the
most help
um we we didn't so there was triage
systems and in poland and
various children were allocated to
various different agencies and we made
it clear from the pediatric intensive
care transport team from southampton
that we would be able to move children
of any level of critical illness
and would not turn children away if
people were worried about how sick they
were and we were able to move all 21
that we were asked
what was their journey like
emotional um they started off obviously
afraid and these
some of the stories of what these
children have been through you i i can't
even begin to imagine
um
and
to have that on its own is bad enough
for anyone but to have that whilst
having treatment for cancer it was just
astronomical so when they got on that
plane and they were scared they were
afraid and language barrier was a
problem we had some incredible
translators and some incredible player
therapists for the children that were
well enough to to be able to um
communicate and talk and interact
and actually as the plane took off you
almost saw a sense of relief that these
families knew that their children were
going to get treatment
and that they had a chance of
surviving their cancer
and actually on landing children that
initially wouldn't make eye contact and
were terrified were high-fiving playing
smiling and it was um just a really it
was it was an honor to be able to
offer the southampton services for the
critical care part of that transport
team and to work with the birmingham
children's hospital oncology team to
deliver this
and before i let you go doctor um i get
the impression that there will be
uh more children who will be able to
make the journey as well what can you
tell us about that
all i can say is that um when this
mission was requested and it was
a fairly straightforward decision to say
yes we will happily offer help
and i have no doubt that the same answer
will occur if we get asked again